inosuke was raised by boars for most of
his life before the final selection it
was revealed later that he was born into
a family with an abusive father and
escaped from his father with his mother
afterward enosuke who was still a baby
at the time and his mother katoa were
taken in by doma into his paradise faith
cult however after discovering that doma
ate his worshippers katoa fled with
anosuke in her arms running aimlessly
towards a human village katoa eventually
ended up at the top of a cliff seeing no
escape route she made a last-ditch
effort to save enosuke by dropping him
into the river below the cliff doma then
devoured her later on inosuke was
discovered and raised by boars will
inosuke manage to become strong enough
to defeat doma and avenge his mother
stick to the end and find out before
final selection a demon slayer bumps
into enosuke on the ladder's mountain
the two then competed to see who was
stronger inosuke was the victor and took
the slayer's weapon as a reward as a
result inosuke learns more about the
demons and decides to join the demon
slayer core final selection arc while a
nosekid does participate in the final
selection at mount fuji kosani he is off
screen for the entirety of the arc
suzumi mansion arc inosuke had wandered
into the kyogai's drum house presumably
looking for a demon to kill to serve as
his catalyst to becoming stronger
unfortunately due to the nature of
kyogai's blood demon art he ended up
trapped for three days he first appears
when zenitsu and soichi are searching
for an exit zenitsu slides open a door
that he believed was the exit and behind
that door is inosuke who immediately
hurtles out and runs down the opened
corridor leaving both of them shocked
later he becomes friends with tantro and
zenitsu and decides to follow them on
their journey before we continue with
enosuke's story and explain his fights
against doma and muzan we want to thank
doki doki palace for sponsoring this
video doki doki palace is a free to play
mobile game where you will become the
prince of the underworld and write your
unique legend the game also has an
android version called izukai demon
waifu so make sure to search for the
correct name when trying to download it
begin your journey in your besieged
stronghold paladina and set forth to
conquer all known and unknown as the
demon prince you will need to take the
responsibilities to protect your people
lead troops to defeat enemies and expand
your demon influence you can recruit
various subordinates and each one of
them has different and unique skills you
can also dress as exquisite as you like
choose your costume and show your taste
in love with the cloth you wear compete
against other players in real time pvp
battles fight for the honor and defeat
them at all costs the game collapsed
with famous anime series like monster
museum and lazdon and there are even
more collaborations to come click the
link in the description to download doki
doki palace or isakai demon waifu now
and become the prince of the underworld
mount not to gumo arc after resting at
the wisteria house due to their injuries
they are summoned by tangero's crow to
head to mount natogumo inosuke and
tandro rush into the mountain and
encounter a demon slayer asking for help
the demon slayer was then quickly pulled
back into the forest with threads after
witnessing that enosuke acts as the
vanguard and orders tanjro and xenotube
to follow him after meeting with another
demon slayer hiding from the demons
inosuke and tangero understand the
situation demon slayers began to kill
each other after entering the woods due
to a demon's blood art making them into
puppets that can be controlled after
trying their best not to kill the
controlled demon slayers inosuke uses
his beast breathing to find the demon
known as mother they proceed to the
demon's location but are stopped by a
headless puppet controlled by the mother
during the battle inosuke's hastiness
gets him injured and almost killed
thankfully tondro saves him and
encourages ennosuke to fight alongside
him enosuke is very competitive with
tanjuro thinking he can do everything
tanjiro can after dealing with the
puppet tondro defeats the mother demon
and enosuke is severely wounded although
he is not willing to admit to it they
catch a glimpse of a demon girl who
tantro could not smell due to the putrid
scent surrounding the mountains the
demon girl calls for another demon
called father a large man with the face
of a spider tondre was sent flying away
due to the demon's strength and shouts
for a nosekeep to not die at all costs
ninosuke manages to cut the demon's arm
making him climb up to trees to shed his
skin and show an even larger spider-like
body inosuke tries to behead the demon
with his beast breathing but his blades
break and the demon starts to strangle
him luckily giyu shows up and
effortlessly kills father with the water
breathing saving in nosql's life inosuke
despite his wounds tries to challenge
giyu but ends up getting tied up to a
tree this makes inosuke's confidence
drop and makes him think he is not as
good as he thought he was rehabilitation
training arc due to the injuries he
sustained from the father inosuke's
throat became mangled so he was taken to
the butterfly mansion to heal alongside
tandro and zenetsu while there inosuke
trained and became much stronger he
started believing in himself again ready
for the next mission inosuke is now much
stronger but he still has a long way to
go before he can challenge doma and
avenge his mother's death mujin train
arc the trio is tasked with killing the
demon on the moojin train as they enter
the train enosuke is his boisterous self
screaming about being inside the train
and causing a ruckus they finally meet
rengoku who has a quick chat with
tanjiro he then reveals he was sent here
because 40 people have disappeared on
this train and none of the swordsmen
have ever returned as a demon appears
from the opposite end of the train
rangoku notes that he could not sense it
but proceeds to draw his sword and
manages to behead the demon with flame
breathing much to their awe the trio
begs when goku to train them to which he
agrees afterward everyone falls into a
deep sleep and inosuke dreams of leading
an underground cave expedition later as
they wake up tantro calls out to enosuke
as the latter burst through the train's
roof and asks him to protect the
passengers warning him that the whole
train is a demon and that no one is safe
when goku tasks tantro and inosuke with
cutting off anu's neck while he and the
others take care of the passengers he
uses beast breathing spatial awareness
to locate enmu's weak point and finds it
at the very front of the train following
his nose inosuke wildly slashes around
and jumps into the front car saying that
this is where the demon smell is the
strongest the conductor is startled and
yells at him to get out but inosuke
ignores him and continues forward
suddenly the demonic in-growths present
in the car form into hands and reach out
to grab him he tries to cut them without
success but is eventually saved by
tanjro having cleared out the area
tundra senses that the demon's stench is
coming from right below them performing
a beast breathing form inosuke slices
the floor and tantro looks on in disgust
to see that enmu's neck bone now runs
through the bottom of the train right
beneath their feet two demon slayers
tried to destroy it but more ingrowths
attack them tangero came up with a plan
one of them would cut all the flesh
while the other would go for the neck
commending this brilliant plan enosuke
agrees but before they can proceed
enroll grows giant eyes and uses his
blood demon art to make demon slayers go
to sleep the eyeballs all get sliced
shut by enosuke and using his beast
breathing he reopens the floor exposing
and moves neck bone this allows tantro
to finally defeat enmu using
hinukamikagura clear blue sky shortly
after rengoku and tantro are ambushed by
akasa and the flame hashira engages in
battle inosuke arrives just in time to
see the two exchange blows and states
that he can't do anything to help since
he would only be in rangoku's way
inosuke and tonjiro watched helplessly
as the dust clears to reveal rangoku
impaled through his solar plexus by
akasa inosuke quickly tries to attack
using beast breathing but the upper rank
manages to dodge at the last moment and
escapes into the forest inosuke begins
to tremble as he watches tundra whale
tears streaming down his face he needs
to become much stronger if he wants to
achieve his goals entertainment district
arc sometime after the infinity train
mission tantro inosuke and zenitsu meet
sound hashira tenjin uzui and they
agreed to go on a mission with him as
the group of boys sets off on the
mission they asked tenjin where they're
going exactly to which he responds the
flashiest place in japan steeped in lust
and avarice ultimately revealing that
they are heading towards the
entertainment district to find his
missing wives as the group arrives
tenjin uses his charming looks to try
and give away the boys disguised as
girls a woman approaches tension and
asks him if he is looking for a house
and offers to take inosuke into the
ogimoto house to which tengen agrees
inside the ogimoto house inosuke starts
to investigate the whereabouts of maquil
and overhears two women conversing in
front of her room the women began to
gossip that makio was feeling unwell and
had not left her room the whole day
suddenly inosuke senses the change in
the atmosphere and rushes into the room
he sees that the room is completely
destroyed and senses the demon hiding in
the ceiling as the demon tries to escape
and nosuke begins to give chase and
rushes down the hallway the demon
manages to get away leaving inosuke
angered later enosuke can be seen
cackling as he discovers a hole leading
to a demon nest he proudly yells at the
hole to prepare itself before diving in
head first once he arrives he discovers
the long trails of the ob draped
throughout the cafern as he takes a
closer look he sees multiple people
being held captive within the obi and
discovers zenitsu knocked out amongst
them as well as he tries to wake him up
the obi begins to move demanding to know
why enosuke is there enosuke begins his
assault against the obi and the women
held captive begin to slip out from the
sections causing the obi to panic as the
nosekeep prepares to slice another
section the ob suddenly becomes more
elastic and folds along in usuke's blade
the obi mentions innos case failure at
protecting the individuals he's freed
claiming that it can easily just swallow
them up again akunai flies out of
nowhere causing the obi to retract two
women appear and explain to inosuke that
they're there to help him and will
protect the others from the obi inosuke
reluctantly agrees but asks them who
they are to which they reveal their
tengen's missing wives suma and makio
shortly after tenjin arrives and easily
destroys the obi a while later in the
middle of a brawl between tension and
upper rank zenitsu and inosuke arrive to
help him as daki attempts to attack
tenjin and tanchoro from behind zenetsu
burst through the home within seconds to
block the attack as inosuke follows him
they asked chandra for help to defeat
daki and he agrees
after some battling inosuke realizes
that she has slowed down and decides to
go for the neck as zenitsu agrees with
tantra to protect him from behind daki
begins to crack under the pressure as
enough skate closes in on her and
manages to drop both of his blades on
either side of her neck finally enosuke
buries his heels into the ground as he
uses beast breathing sixth fang palisade
bite to decapitate daki having
successfully decapitated daki enosuke
can be seen escaping with her head in
order to prevent her from reattaching it
he tells his comrades not to worry about
him and to help tenjin instead however
before he can get away giutaro appears
behind him and impales him through the
chest inosuke falls to the ground and
everyone assumes that he is dead
some time later zenetsu can be seen
trying to decapitate docky she attempts
to use her obi to kill him at close
range but inosuke unexpectedly rushes to
the scene revealing that he is alive he
explains that he protected his heart
from being stabbed by rearranging his
organs he also reveals that poisons do
not affect him since he was raised in
the mountains before proceeding to
assist zenitsu in decapitating daki the
three boys roar as they muster the
strength to slice through the demon's
necks after the long battle zenitsu and
inosuke managed to decapitate daki on
the rooftop while tonjiro can be seen
decapitating gyotaro simultaneously on
the ground with this the trio has
successfully defeated the upper ranked
demons a feat that hasn't been achieved
in over 100 years with this enosuke is
one step closer to doma and their fight
is inevitable ashira training arc a
while later after the incident at the
swordsmith village hashirits have a
meeting where they decide to start the
so-called hashira training program in
order to gain more strength for their
upcoming fight against muzon the trio
trains under stone hashira however their
training is cut short after sanemi finds
out that their location has been
compromised and that kagaya is in danger
as muzon comes to his house all demon
slayers rushed to the ubiashiki family
home to find it already blown up as
kagaya said explosives around the house
to kill muzon as the demon slayers try
to engage muzon giant doors suddenly
appear and slide open under them causing
all of them to plummet into the infinity
castle muzon mocks them for believing
they had him cornered and declares he
will kill them all tonight after the
long journey enosuke's battle against
doma is just around the corner is he
strong enough to defeat him and finally
avenge his mother infinity castle arc
inside infinity castle canal is battling
doma as the demon sends his blood demon
art at canal enosuke suddenly breaks
through the room's ceiling protecting
canal from doma's attack he looks at
doma's eyes and notices that he's upper
rank too he screams out happily shouting
that if he beats the demon he'll become
a hashira and asking canal what his
shira title should be canal reveals to
him that shinobu is dead doma has killed
her enosuke recalls shinobu's kindness
to him and vows to doma that he'll kill
him as he rushes towards the upper rank
with his beast breathing doma attempts
to slice off inosika's head with one of
his fans but the demon slayer launches
himself from the edge of the fan and
lands next to canal he hands her her
blade which doma took from her earlier
and tells her never to let go of it
again enos doma swiftly engaged in quick
combat launching breath styles and blood
demon arts at each other at incredible
speeds enos kid kicks doma in the
stomach sending him skidding backward as
he dislocates the joints in his arm and
prepares to swing his sword at the upper
rank's neck unfortunately he misjudges
his swing and instead slices through
doma's eyes with his beasts breathing
dumbo launches himself forward at an
incredible speed and snatches his mask
from his head enosuke enraged yells at
him to give it back but instead the
demon looks at his face and says he
remembers inosuke from somewhere asking
him if they'd met before enosuke
responds that they hadn't as he never
saw dumbo before in his life dumber
remembers that he knew anosuke's mother
as she joined his cult but inosuke
denies having a mother since boer has
raised him doma laughs at this answer
and tells hinosuke that he must have a
human mother since he is a human this
enrages enosuke and he quickly attacks
doma with his beast breathing however he
is slashed by doma who tells him not to
interrupt them when he speaks doma then
tells the story of katoa inosuke's
mother memories of her begin to come
back to anosuke who recalls the songs
she used to sing to him enraged enosuke
says that he will not only kill doma for
what he did to her mother and shinobu
but also put him through hell beforehand
doma smiles again and tells innocek that
there is no heaven or hell in this world
enosuka shouts that he doesn't care he
can just make one himself and tells
domin not to ever talk about his mother
again the battle begins to pick up the
demon sends his freezing clouds at
enosuke which he blows away with his
beast breathing as canal prepares to use
another breath style to attack him from
behind doma bats her away with one of
his fans and moves away inosuke yells at
him to get back here so they can
continue fighting he replies that since
akaza is dead he doesn't have time to
play games anymore doma then uses his
blood demon art to create smaller clones
of himself for inosuka and canal to
fight instead the clones attack the
demon slayer due as the real domes
starts to walk away while at the exit
domo overhears canal shouting to enosuke
that they have to hold their ground just
a little bit longer doma is confused and
wonders what she means by this but
starts to exit anyway
suddenly doma's entire body begins to
melt and he drops to the floor enosuke
asked if this is some kind of trap but
canal tells him that it isn't she then
explains that this was a plan all along
and that doma is melting from the poison
that shinobu had on her body when he
consumed her she tells innocent to aim
for the neck and finish him off in a
panic doma activates his most powerful
technique blood demon art rime water
lily bahisaka doma's ice barizatfa
statue slams down its hand on the floor
creating a small earthquake that sends
inosuke and canal up into the air dome's
statue grabs inosuke as canal leaps
towards the upper rank hitting her blade
against his neck she is unable to cut it
so inosuke on the spot comes up with the
new beast breathing technique sudden
throwing strike he hurls his blades at
canals to give it the extra strength
needed to cut doma's neck they succeed
in beheading him and the demon starts to
disintegrate although they managed to
defeat the upper rank 2 the night isn't
over and there is still one final battle
to be fought sunrise countdown arc
sometime later the infinite castle
collapses and the remaining demon
slayers fight against muzon on the
streets suddenly with no demon slayers
around him muzon's arms get sliced he
questions this and soon realizes that
there must be someone else here enosuke
canal and zenetsu suddenly appear as the
invisibility seals placed on their heads
get sliced off by muzon's attacks they
are taken aback at how quickly he
figured out their strategy however gyome
is pleasantly surprised to see them all
still alive as inosuke boasts that he
wouldn't die and had plenty of seals to
spare irritated muzan interrupts in
nosql's monologue and swipes at him with
a whip but he manages to dodge suddenly
muzon performs his special attack
crushing all the demon slayers including
enosuke into nearby buildings knocking
them unconscious at this point tanjuro
wakes up and starts battling muzon one
on one eventually he is defeated and
grievously injured and muzon starts
escaping
the demon stops in his tracks as inosuke
jumps in front of him with his beast
breathing stating
you sure got me back there you are dead
now enraged muzan plans to attack
enosuke but can't perform any of his
techniques due to fatigue enosuke
continues talking they protected us
yome's leg and giu's arm got cut off all
of these corpses everywhere are the
bodies i ate my food with give them back
the leg the arm the lives give them back
muzon launches an attack at anos ga who
manages to jump out of the way but just
as he is about to land muzon sends his
right arm whips into the ground to catch
anosuke from below managing to capture
the young demon slayer as all hope seems
lost tonjiro yells at enosuke not to die
suddenly anosuke is saved by zenetsu who
slices through muzon's arm with he yells
at tantro to stay alive and tries to
bolster his spirits by telling him that
he must survive so they can all go back
and lift together muzon smacks zenitsu
into a building but in this case quickly
slices his whip to prevent further
damage the demon is infuriated and
attacks in nosuke once again exhausted
muzon looks on as zenitsu and onosuke
stand up again after being knocked down
and notes that he cannot raise his arms
anymore everyone prays for the success
of those fighting muzon as inosuke and
zinitsu continue their attempts to hold
the demon back enosuke performs his
beast breathing to chop off some of
muzon's whips and zenetsu follows it up
with a thunderbreathing godspeed muzon
is enraged and unleashes a shock away
from his torso mouth that flings inosuke
back however before musang can do
anything else tondro intervenes and
rapidly performs multiple sun breathing
forms after the combined effort of the
trio they finally manage to corner muzon
as the sun rises muzon starts panicking
and transforms himself into a giant baby
all demon slayers give their all to try
to stop muzan from retreating into the
shadows
eventually the sun rises disintegrating
muzan kibutsuji once and for all but
this victory didn't come without many
sacrifices including tanjuro who gave
his life fighting muzon
as guillo kneels in front of tanjuro's
lifeless body he is shocked to see
tandro opening his eyes revealing that
he has become a demon giul jumps on
tanjro to prevent him from reaching the
shade inosi stands over him and tries to
remind tantro that giu is their ally
tantro crouches down and bears his fangs
at anosuke who can only look on quietly
at what has become of his friend tandro
leaps forward to attack anosuke who
prepares to fight him enosuke thinks
back to their time together and says
that they are all comrades like brothers
who would pull each other back if one of
them started going down the wrong path
anosuke thinks to himself that he needs
to stop tantro before he kills someone
suddenly he is hit by a memory of tanjro
offering him some fish to eat together
with a smile on his face enosuke stops
mid-swipe and is unable to complete his
attack tearing up and saying it was no
use and that he can't attack tontaro
nezuku rushes forward and hugs her
brother apologizing for being a burden
all this time and asking him to come
home tonjero lets out a howl but is
interrupted by enosuke repeatedly
hitting him on the head he tells his
friend to snap out of it and go back to
being his usual kind self angered tantro
sends out a shock wave that flings
inosuke zenitsu and gilu back as nezuku
desperately clings on to her brother out
of nowhere canal jumps into the scene
and manages to inject tundra with
medicine thus making him human again
nezugu calls out tanjuro's name and he
apologizes to everyone for bringing them
harm everyone begins to cheer upon
hearing his voice and with this the
battle against the demons that lasted
for generations is finally over click on
this video where we explained the entire
story of muzon kibutsuji don't be shy
click it